pensemos ahora un poco sobre las
gráficas del valor absoluto de funciones
he definido un aquí es fx es igual a
menos 3 que multiplica al valor absoluto
de x menos uno más 9 ok y vamos a
restringir su dominio vamos a definirlo
para los valores x que se encuentran
entre menos 4 y 5 muy bien entonces te
invito a que hagas una pausa y que
trates de ver cómo se graficar y a esta
función en el plano coordinado y por
supuesto puedes pensar en darle valores
a la gráfica o más bien darle valores a
la función para ir obteniendo puntos
sobre la gráfica pero sería mucho más
importante que pienses en su estructura
por ejemplo donde se encuentran los
máximos que forman tienen
entonces para ir trabajando en este
ejemplo no tenemos que esta parte de
aquí que está en el valor absoluto o
bueno este valor absoluto es siempre
mayor o igual que 0 es decir es no
negativo y cuando decimos no negativo
quiere decir que puede ser 0 o algo
positivo muy bien sin embargo en
realidad estamos multiplicando por un
menos 3 y ese menos 3 es algo negativo
así que en conjunto todo esto va a ser
menor o igual que 0 y eso quiere decir
que es no positivo muy bien toda esta
parte es no positivo y después le
sumamos 9 ahora bien como podríamos
encontrar el máximo de esta función si
nos fijamos el 9 es fijo bueno el 9 el 9
no se mueve y finalmente para encontrar
el máximo pues tenemos que restarle lo
menos posible entonces quizás sería
buena idea buscar en qué puntos de esta
función esto se hace cero para que no le
restemos
no le restemos a este 9 entonces la
forma de encontrar los valores para los
cuales esto se hace 0 es viendo cuando
el valor absoluto de x menos uno es
igual a cero verdad porque estamos
multiplicando por menos 3 así que esto
sería 0 si esta parte de dentro del
valor absoluto lo es y sabemos que el
valor absoluto es cero si sólo si lo que
está dentro del valor absoluto que es x
menos 1 vale 0 o lo que es lo mismo que
x es igual a 1 si sumamos uno de ambos
lados entonces ya vimos que en el 1 este
este digamos este término vale 0 y si le
sumamos 9 entonces estamos en este punto
de aquí es decir el punto 19 es nuestro
máximo
y sabemos además que los valores
absolutos digamos de expresiones
lineales se ven de esta forma se ven de
esta forma cuando el coeficiente que
antecede al valor absoluto es positivo y
como ese no es nuestro caso entonces se
verá de esta forma es la forma que
tendrá nuestra función o la gráfica de
nuestra función muy bien ya más o menos
puedes intuir cómo se va a ir viendo
para ello vamos a ir escribiendo esta
función en dos pedazos por ejemplo qué
pasa si la x es mayor o igual que 1 pero
menor o igual que 5 o bien que esté por
abajo del 1 es decir que x sea menor o
igual que 1 pero tiene que ser mayor o
igual que menos 4 muy bien entonces
vamos a vamos a ver si x es mayor o
igual que 1 el valor absoluto de x menos
1 es mayor o igual que 0 así que se
queda exactamente igual verdad x menos 1
- 3 x x menos uno
9 de hecho vamos vamos a reescribir lo
mejor vamos a distribuir este producto
tendremos menos 3 por x menos uno más 9
esto es menos 13 x + 3 9 y esto es menos
3 x más 12 muy bien entonces en esta
parte de 1 a 5 de hecho lo podemos ver
aquí entre 1 y 5 vamos a tener que la
función obedece la siguiente regla menos
13 x más 12 muy bien y lo importante de
aquí es que podemos ver podemos ver
podemos ver que es una pendiente
negativa de valor 3 del valor menos 3
entonces quiere decir que por cada uno
un cuadro que nos movemos a la derecha
tenemos que bajar tenemos que bajar 3
muy bien nos movemos uno a la derecha
bajamos 3 1 a la derecha bajamos 3 1 la
derecha bajamos 3 entonces esto se verá
como una línea
de este estilo
con pendiente negativa igual a 3 muy
bien ahí lo tienen más o menos así se ve
la gráfica digamos de este lado ahora
pensemos qué ocurre si estamos entre
menos no no es menos 5 es menos 4 y 1
ok en este caso pues sera
perdón será una pendiente positiva muy
bien de hecho cuando tenemos x menor o
igual que 1 el valor absoluto de x menos
1 pues será igual a menos x menos uno
verdad porque en ese caso x menos 1 es
negativo y el valor absoluto debe ser
debe ser mayor o igual que 0 entonces
esto simplemente nos queda 1 x
de ahí que nuestra función fx sea igual
a menos 3 por el valor absoluto de x
menos uno que es 1 - x + 9 y esto es
menos tres más 3x esto es distribuyendo
el producto más 9 entonces tenemos 3x y
9 menos 3 son 6 así que en este lado la
función se ve como 3x + 6 quiere decir
que tenemos una pendiente positiva es
decir por cada uno que nos movemos a la
derecha subimos 3 o si lo vemos al revés
por cada uno que nos movemos a la
izquierda bajamos 3 muy bien para partir
de este vértice entonces si estamos aquí
1 a la izquierda y bajamos 3
uno a la izquierda y bajamos 3 1 a la
izquierda y bajamos 3 1 a la izquierda y
bajamos 3 y aquí ya hemos bajado
bastante verdad aquí está muy bien
entonces la gráfica de nuestra función
es justo una recta de pendiente 3 y que
de hecho aquí se ve que pasa por el 6 de
verdad muy bien entonces ahí tienen
ustedes la gráfica de nuestra función f
x aquí realmente logramos obtener esta
gráfica simplemente haciendo un análisis
de nuestra función y fue un análisis muy
detallado uno podría a lo mejor ir
tomando valores distintos de x para ir
graficando puntos sin embargo aquí lo
hicimos completo el análisis una
moraleja de esto es analizar los puntos
o qué bueno que es una buena estrategia
encontrar dónde está el máximo o el
mínimo del valor absoluto para poder
encontrar digamos el vértice de esta
gráfica a partir de ello todo es
muchísimo más sencillo si lo partimos
digamos
dos pedazos en donde podemos analizar
muy bien cómo se ve la gráfica entonces
bien pudiste haber tomado valores para
ir graficando esta función sin embargo
ahora hicimos un verdadero y profundo
análisis de la función para entenderlo
mejor yo creo que así es como lo veo yo
que es mucho mejor y de hecho es mucho
más emocionante entenderlo como desde
una perspectiva analítica a simplemente
ir graficando puntos nos da una mejor
lección